this is progress and it's a testament to
our new strategy of
growing this economy from the bottom up
in the middle out
it's a clear testament to why it's so
needed
some critics said that we didn't need
the american the american rescue plan
that this economy would just uh heal
itself
today's report just underscores in my
view
how vital the actions we're taking are
obviously very disappointing numbers
this morning we're getting a little
orwellian with uh when it comes to the
language we hear from this
administration sometimes
i'm hoping this is an anomaly that we
see with this disappointing jobs number
and that
we'll be back on a much more robust path
in the coming weeks and months
well the president uh saying this is
just part of the progress in the plan
for the u.s economy and that it's on the
right track republicans
other experts saying this was a really
bad jobs report 266
000 jobs added six point one percent
unemployment rate
they were expecting nine hundred seventy
five thousand jobs
added for april maybe even a million uh
what about this
and the state of the us economy and
where we're headed let's bring in our
panel charles hurt opinion editor
for the washington times harold ford jr
former tennessee congressman ceo of
empowerment
and inclusion capital and jonah goldberg
editor-in-chief
of the dispatch jonah every white house
tries to do a little spin
this was major spin if you're missing it
by
900 000 jobs
yeah i mean this was the kind of spin
that you risk internal torsion
um for uh look the daniel patrick
moynihan
used to use a phrase called iatrogenic
government and it was a reference to
when doctors trying to treat a problem
actually create problems
uh there is a lot of there's a lot of
reason to be concerned that the
overly excessive unemployment insurance
is actually dampening down demand for
jobs not demand on the from
employers but from uh people not willing
to
give up very generous and not in many
cases necessary benefits
and it's a very weird spin from this
administration to say
that they're um everything that they're
they've spent trillions on creating jobs
bragging about the jobs and then when
the jobs don't materialize
they immediately say well that means we
have to spend trillions more
yeah and so that issue about
unemployment benefits keeps on coming up
and the white house keeps on pushing
back in fact the treasury secretary was
out
white house press secretary being asked
these questions about unemployment
benefits take a listen
starting up an economy again trying to
get it back on track after a pandemic in
which there are a lot of supply
bottlenecks
is going to be i think a bumpy product
process but i really don't think the
major
factor is the extra unemployment though
some individual employers may be
experiencing
increased difficulty finding workers we
haven't seen
widespread labor shortages are not yet
evident in the data
i'm not sure harold how they can say
that as far as
i mean we're hearing anecdotally from a
lot of businesses around the country
that are having a hard time finding
workers
that very well could be the case but you
know i served in congress 10 years and
these big moments
remind me of times when both parties do
the easy thing
they both retreat to the sound and fury
and the talking points of the moment
we should be organizing everything we do
economically
everything we do from a national
security standpoint around the words
from our secretary of state
former the words of our former uh cia
director and secretary of defense bob
gates who you had on just the other
night
this is about a challenge with china and
don't get me wrong i'm not i'm not
suggesting that they're not some issues
with the
employment force and finding ways to
ensure to incentivize people going back
to work but this is a small moment and a
huge
in a huge feature film here if we don't
figure out ways to invest
in the things that we need to invest in
for the next five to ten to fifteen to
twenty years of a battle
of a new cold war then we're kidding
ourselves and if we don't find ways to
do
uh what what what young mr schreiber
said a little while ago about how we
find ways to come together
which means that joe biden ought to be
focused on a bipartisan deal on
infrastructure
we've done he's done the things he had
to do with his own party it's now time
to advance
something that's going to advance the
country with broad support even if that
means coming down from the 1.9 trillion
which democrats have laid out from the
outset
well listen harold the fact that you
have a lot of people on on
[Music]
wall street now saying that the market
improved today
because they saw the bad jobs report and
said
well that takes away the concern about
the overheating
that a lot of people were worried about
that they're just pumping tons and tons
of money in here and then
that it was going to be supercharged it
still may
but that was one of the reasons people
thought the markets went up today
it might have might have been but i mean
if you're we're going to be in the
business of trying to predict what
moves these markets when president trump
was elected that night it dropped and it
rose again later the next morning so the
market can correct itself
quickly i think what the market wants is
some predictability stability and i can
promise you this
if we don't find ways to counter compete
with
and show that we can beat china our
market won't respond favorably in the
long term
charlie what about this today big
picture well i think that uh without a
doubt you can't ignore the fact that uh
one thing a lot of people are not
talking about right now is that
the jobs numbers has to be affected
somewhat by the fact that so many
schools are still closed
and a lot of families uh you know uh you
know plan their working
uh schedule around schools and when
schools are closed it's kind of hard to
go to school
for you to work uh but there's no doubt
uh that the
when you pay people to stay home and not
work if the federal government does that
that people are going to
stay home and not work and the idea that
somebody like janet yellen is going to
sit there and
argue that that has no effect she really
should get out of the business of
economics because i'm not an economist
but obviously
if so if the government's going to pay
you to do something people are going to
do it
but i think you know the most startling
thing about all of this is to look at
the
enthusiasm on wall street and listen to
somebody like joe biden talk about how
this is all great news when obviously
it's not great news
and honestly i think that what wall
street is seeing is they look at the
southern border and they see
thousands and thousands of people they
view that as cheap labor coming across
the border
and that's why they think that this is
so great they don't it doesn't bother
them that americans are not going back
to work
not finding uh good employment not
finding good jobs
as long as they get cheap labor coming
into this country and joe biden is doing
nothing to stop it that's great for them
as far as they're concerned
yeah i i don't think a lot of people are
surprised when people
that make more by staying home are
choosing to stay home all right winners
and losers here
uh jonah um the
my winner this week are the uh divorce
attorneys
for uh bill and melinda gates they're
gonna do just great
um and my loser is mayor washington d.c
mayor muriel bowser who's decided that
in order to prime the economy
she's going to cast dc as the set for
the
a new version of footloose by banning
dancing
[Laughter]
all right harold winner and loser my
winner is a detroit river that was good
jonah my winner is the detroit river
in the sturgeon fish family seven feet
240 pounds
huge and experienced a hundred years old
this female fish was found back in 1900
there were 700 500
000 sturgeon detroit river today only 7
000 but the u.s fish and wildlife
preservation believes this fine means
good things my loser those governors who
want to stop people from voting
florida texas let's win on ideas not by
suppressing the vote
all right charlie winner or loser uh
winner is the olympian formerly known as
bruce jenner who uh is one of the
greatest
uh athletes of all time uh made a made a
name for himself that way and
uh now looks like uh maybe
on on a path to become california's
first
female governor which is truly truly
remarkable only in california
loser of the week are the pharmaceutical
companies who
perform miracles by inventing these
vaccines
joe biden and is colluding with the
world health organization to strip them
of their patents
file that under no no good deed goes
unpunished
there you go panel sounds good thank you
make it a great weekend
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else